we've been doing a bunch of these videos
with these convex lenses where we drew
parallel rays and rays that go through
the focal point to figure out what the
image of an object might be but what i
want to do in this video is actually
come up with an algebraic relationship
between
between the distance of the object from
the convex lens the distance of the
image from from the convex lens usually
on the other side and the focal length
and the focal length let's see if we can
do this and just to save you the pain of
having to watch me draw straight lines i
drew this ahead of time and so we could
imagine this green thing right here is
the object this is the object and these
two little pink points right here are
the focal points
they're a focal length away and i did
what we always do i draw drew one
parallel ray from the tip of that arrow
to
the actual convex lens and then it gets
refracted so it goes through the focal
point on the right hand side and goes
all the way over there
and then i drew a ray that goes through
the focal point on the left hand side
and then when it gets refracted it
becomes parallel and then it actually
intersects with that previous
that previous ray up right over here and
so this gives us
this gives us a sense of what the image
what the image will look like it's
inverted it's real in this case it is
larger than the actual object what i
want to do is come for the relationship
with these values so let's see if we can
label them here and then just do a
little bit of geometry and a little bit
algebra to figure out if there is an
algebraic relationship right here so the
first the first number the distance of
the object that's this distance from
here to here or we can just label it
here since this is already drawn for us
this is the distance of the object
this is the way we drew it this was the
this was the parallel light ray but
before it got refracted it traveled the
distance of the from the object to the
actual lens now the distance of from the
image to the lens that's this right over
here this is how far this parallel light
ray
this parallel light ray had to travel so
this is the distance
from the image to the lens
and then we have the focal distance
the focal length and that's just this
distance right here
this right here is our focal length or
we could view it on this side as well
this right here
is also
is also our focal length so i want to
come up with some relationship
and to do that i'm going to draw some
triangles here so what we can do is and
the whole strategy i'm going to keep
looking for similar triangles and then
trying to find if i can find try to see
if i can find relationships or ratios
that relate these three things to each
other so let me find some similar
triangles so the best thing i can think
of to do is let me redraw this triangle
over here let me just flip it over let
me just draw the same triangle on the
right hand side of this diagram so this
so if i were to draw the same triangle
it would look like this
it would look like
this
and let me just be clear this is this
triangle right over here i just flipped
it over
i just flipped it over
and so if we want to make sure we're
keeping track of the same sides if this
length right here is d sub zero or d
naught sometimes we could call it or d
zero or whatever you want to call it
then this length up here
this length up here is also going to be
d0
these are and the reason why i wanted to
do that is because now we can do
something interesting we can relate this
triangle up here to this triangle down
here and actually we can see that
they're going to be similar and then we
can relate and then we can get some
ratios of sides and then what we're
going to do is try to show that this
triangle over here is similar to this
triangle over here get a couple of more
ratios and then we might be able to
relate all of these things so the first
thing we have to prove to ourselves is
that those triangles really are similar
so the first thing to realize
this angle right here is definitely the
same thing as that angle right over
there they're sometimes called opposite
angles or vertical angles they're on the
opposite side of lines that are
intersecting so they're going to be
equal
now the next thing and this comes out of
the fact that both of these lines this
line is parallel
to that line right over there and you
could look at you could i guess you
could call it alternate alternate
interior angles if you look at the
angles game or the parallel lines or the
transversal of a parallel lines from
geometry we know that this angle since
they're alternating interior angles this
angle is going to be the same value as
this angle
right because they're both you can view
this line right here as a transversal
and these of two parallel lines these
are alternate interior angles so they
will be the same now we can make that
exact same argument we can make that
exact same argument for this angle
and this angle
and so we see is this triangle up here
has the same three angles as this
triangle down here so these two
triangles are similar
these are both
this is really more of a review of
geometry than optics these are similar
triangles
similar they're similar i don't have to
write triangles they're similar
and because they're similar the ratios
of corresponding sides are going to be
the same
so d naught corresponds to this they're
both opposite they're both opposite this
pink angle
they're both opposite that pink angle so
the ratio of d naught to d one let me
write this over here so the ratio of d
naught let me write this a little bit
neater the ratio of d naught to d one so
these the ratio of corresponding sides
is going to be the same thing and let me
make some labels here that's going to be
the same thing as the ratio of this side
right over here this side right over
here we call i'll call that a it's
opposite it's opposite
it's opposite this magenta angle right
over here
that's going to be the same thing as the
ratio of that side to this side over
here to side b and once again we can
keep track of it because side b is
opposite the magenta angle on this
bottom triangle so that's how we know
that this side is its corresponding side
and the other similar triangle is that
one they're both opposite the magenta
angles so we know d naught is to d1 as a
is to be
as
a
is to be so that's interesting we've
been able to relate these two things to
some to these kind of two arbitrary
lengths but we need to somehow connect
those to the focal length and what we
could to to connect them to a focal
length what we might want to do is
relate a and b
a sits on the same triangle as the focal
length right over here so let's look at
this triangle right over here let me
pick it let me put in a better color so
let's look at this triangle right over
here that i'm highlighting in green
this triangle in green and let's look at
that in comparison to this triangle that
i'm also highlighting
this triangle that i'm also highlighting
in green
now the first thing i want to show you
is that these are also similar triangles
this angle
right over here and this angle are going
to be the same they are opposite angles
of intersecting lines and then we can
make we can make a similar argument
alternate interior angles oh there's a
couple arguments we can make one you can
see that this is a right angle right
over here this is a right angle if two
angles of two triangles are the same the
third angle also has to be the same so
we could also say that this thing
let me just do this in another color
because i don't want to be repetitive
too much with the colors we can say that
this thing is going to be the same thing
as this thing or another way you could
have said it is you said well this is
this line up over here
which is kind of represented by the lens
or the lens that the line that is
parallel to the lens or right along the
lens is parallel to
the kind of the object right over there
and then you could make the same
alternate interior argument there but
the other thing is just look i have two
triangles two of the angles and those
two triangles are the same so the third
angle has to be the same
now since all three angles are the same
these are also both similar triangles so
we can do a similar thing we can say a
is to b remember both a and b are
opposite the 90 degree side they're both
the hypotenuse of these similar
triangles so a is to b
as
we could say
this base length right here and it got
overwritten a little bit but this base
length right over here is f that's our
focal length as f
as f in this triangle is related to this
length on this triangle
they are both opposite that white angle
they're both opposite that wide angle so
as f is to this length right over here
now what's this length so this whole
distance is d i all the way over here
but this length is that whole distance
minus the focal length so this is d i
minus the focal length so a is to b as f
is to
d i
minus the focal length and there you
have it we have a relationship between
the distance of the object the distance
of the image and the focal length and
now we just have to do a little bit of
algebra if this is equal to this and
this is equal to that then this blue
thing has to be equal to this magenta
thing and now we just have to do some
algebra so let's do that so we got
d naught or d zero i guess we call it to
d i is equal to is equal to the ratio of
the focal length to the difference of
the
the image distance
the to the this the focal length to the
image distance minus the focal length
and here we just have to do some algebra
so let's just to simplify this let's
cross multiply it so if we multiply d
naught times this thing over here
we get
d naught d i
i'm really just distributing it
minus d naught f
minus d naught f i'm just distributing
this d naught
just cross multiplying which is really
just the same thing as multiplying both
sides by both denominators or
multiplying with the denominators twice
either way that's all cross multiplying
is that is going to be equal to d i
is going to be equal to
d i
times f
is going to be equal to d i times f and
now we can add this term right over here
to both sides of this equation i'm just
going to switch to a neutral color so we
get d naught
d i
is equal to i'm just adding this to both
sides when you add to the left side it
obviously cancels out is equal to d i f
this thing over here plus
d not f
and then let's see we could factor out a
an f a focal length
so we get d naught
d i is equal to f
times d i plus
d naught and then what can we do we can
we could divide both sides by f so this
will become over f
this becomes
this becomes over f
essentially essentially canceling it out
and then i just want to skip too many
steps let me just rewrite what we have
here so then so these cancel out so we
have d naught
d i over f
over f
is equal to d i
plus d o
and now let's divide both sides by d
naught d i so 1 over d naught d i
divide this side by d naught d i
cancels out over here and so we are left
with on the left hand side 1 over the
focal length is equal to
this thing over here and we can separate
this thing out this thing over here
this is the same thing we just separate
out the numerators the same thing as d i
over d naught d i
plus d naught
but d i over d naught d i the d i's
cancel out we just have a one here the d
naughts cancel out you just have a one
so this is equal to one over the
distance of the object
and this is plus
1 over the distance of the image so
right from the get-go this was a
completely valid formula we actually had
achieved what we wanted but this is even
a much this is a neater formula you
don't have the dis repeated in the f
repeated right here we have an algebraic
relationship for a convex mirror that
relates the focal length to the distance
of the object
and the distance of the image
anyway
i think that's that's pretty neat how it
came out to be at least a pretty clean
formula